vítej zpět u kurzu Porozumění kvantové informaci a výpočtům, jmenuji se John Watrous a jsem technický ředitel pro vzdělávání v IBM
Quantum. Toto je lekce číslo 15 série a třetí lekce čtvrté jednotky věnující se kvantové korekci
chyb. Dosud jsme viděli několik příkladů kvantových kódů opravujících chyby, včetně devítiqubitového Shorova
kódu, sedmiqubitového Steanova kódu a pětiqubitového kódu, a diskutovali jsme formalizmus stabilizátorů, který poskytuje
matematický základ, z něhož můžeme popisovat a analyzovat tyto a mnoho dalších kvantových kódů opravujících chyby.
Kódy, které jsem právě zmínil, jsou bezpochyby zajímavé a představují přirozené místo, kde začít
průzkum kvantové korekce chyb. Problém je, že mohou tolerovat pouze velmi nízkou míru chyb.
Opravit chybu na jednom qubit z pěti, sedmi nebo devíti není špatné, ale s největší pravděpodobností, alespoň jak se domníváme,
budeme muset být schopni tolerovat mnohem více chyb, abychom učinili rozsáhlé kvantové výpočty
realitou. V této lekci se poprvé podíváme na sofistikovanější konstrukty kvantových kódů opravujících chyby, včetně kódů, které mohou
tolerovat mnohem vyšší míru chyb než ty, které jsme dosud viděli, a jsou považovány za slibné kandidáty pro praktickou kvantovou korekci chyb ve
skutečných fyzických zařízeních. Zde je stručný přehled lekce. Začneme třídou
kvantových kódů opravujících chyby, která se nazývá CSS kódy, pojmenovaných po výzkumnících, kteří je poprvé objevili: Robertu Calderbankovi, Peteru
Shorovi a Andrewu Steaneovi. Konstrukce CSS kódu umožňuje vzít určité páry klasických
kódů opravujících chyby a kombinovat je do kvantového kódu opravujícího chyby. Jako součást této diskuse se
poměrně rychle podíváme na klasické lineární kódy a budeme také hovořit o některých základních vlastnostech CSS
kódů. Druhá část lekce pojednává o kódu známém jako Toricův kód, což je základní a skutečně
krásný příklad kvantového kódu opravujícího chyby, který může tolerovat relativně vysokou míru chyb. Ve skutečnosti
Toricův kód není jediným příkladem kvantového kódu opravujícího chyby, ale spíše jde o nekonečnou rodinu kódů, jeden pro
každé kladné celé číslo počínaje dvěma. A v poslední části lekce stručně probereme několik dalších
rodin kvantových kódů, včetně povrchových kódů, které úzce souvisejí s Toricovým kódem, jakož i
barevných kódů. Klasické kódy opravující chyby se studují od 40. let 20. století
a je to fascinující a bohaté téma. Lineární kódy jsou možná nejjednodušším typem klasických kódů
opravujících chyby a vysvětlím přesně, co slovo lineární v tomto kontextu znamená, za chvíli. Jeden jednoduchý
způsob, jak vyjádřit, co jsou, je, že jsou to stabilizátorové kódy, které se náhodou stávají klasickými, a brzy uvidíme, že
CSS kódy jsou v podstatě páry klasických lineárních kódů, které jsou kombinovány dohromady k vytvoření kvantového kódu
opravujícího chyby. Takže pro potřeby té diskuse budeme muset rozumět několika základním věcem o
klasických lineárních kódech. Nejdříve budeme pro celou tuto diskusi brát Σ jako binární abecedu.
Nyní, když hovoříme o klasickém lineárním kódu, myslíme tím množinu C binárních řetězců délky n pro nějaké
kladné celé číslo n, splňující pouze jednu základní vlastnost: pokud jsou u a v binární řetězce v C, pak řetězec
u XOR v je také v C. Mimochodem, u XOR v zde znamená bitový exkluzivní nebo u a v, stejně
jako jsme viděli vícekrát v lekcích pět a šest v části série o kvantových algoritmech, a to je to, co znamená, že je
klasický kód lineární. V podstatě přemýšlíme o binárních řetězcích délky n jako o n-dimenzionálních vektorech,
jejichž složky jsou buď nula nebo jedna, ale místo běžného vektorového sčítání nad reálnými nebo komplexními
čísly používáme sčítání modulo 2, což je jednoduše XOR. Takže pokud máme
dvě kódová slova u a v, tedy u a v jsou binární řetězce v C, pak u plus v modulo 2, neboli jinak řečeno u XOR
v, musí být také kódovým slovem v C. Mimochodem, tato implikace musí platit i tehdy, pokud se u rovná v. Nic to
nevylučuje, a to implikuje, že každý klasický lineární kód musí obsahovat řetězec samých nul, protože
bitový XOR libovolného řetězce se sebou samým dá řetězec samých nul. Například tříbitový
opakovací kód je klasický lineární kód. Konkrétně existují dvě možné volby pro u a dvě možné
volby pro v, a je docela triviální projít možnými páry a zjistit, že vždy dostaneme kódové slovo, když vezmeme bitový
XOR. Zde je jiný příklad, který se nazývá Hammingův kód 7-4-3. Jde o jeden z úplně prvních klasických kódů
opravujících chyby, který byl kdy objeven, a skládá se z 16 binárních řetězců délky sedm. Existuje velmi jednoduchá logika
za výběrem těchto řetězců, ale v tomto videu ji nebudu vysvětlovat. Měl bych také zmínit, že někdy tyto řetězce uvidíš obrácené, ale
prozatím je hlavním bodem to, že pokud vezmeme libovolné dva z těchto řetězců a provedeme XOR, dostaneme jiný řetězec v
kódu. Je to tedy lineární kód, a zápis 7-4-3 v jednoduchých závorkách znamená něco analogického dvojitým
závorkám, které jsem zmínil v předchozí lekci pro stabilizátorové kódy, ale zde je to pro klasické lineární
kódy. Konkrétně kódová slova mají sedm bitů, existuje 16 kódových slov, takže pomocí kódu lze zakódovat čtyři bity, a
stává se, že je to kód se vzdáleností tři, což znamená, že musíš přehodit alespoň tři bity libovolného kódového slova, abys dostal
jiné kódové slovo. To znamená, že může opravit až jednu chybu přehození bitu. To jsou jednoduché příklady
kódů, ale i příklad Hammingova kódu 7-4-3 vypadá poněkud záhadně, když jednoduše vypíšeme všechna kódová slova, takže potřebujeme lepší způsoby, jak
klasické lineární kódy popisovat. Existují dva přirozené způsoby, jak to udělat. Jedním způsobem je popis klasických
lineárních kódů pomocí minimální sady kódových slov, která generují kód, ve smyslu, že vzít všechny možné
podmnožiny těchto kódových slov a provést XOR dá celý kód. To je vyjádřeno v matematických termínech
na obrazovce. Jiný způsob, jak na to myslet, je, že sledujeme tento kód jako podprostor vektorového prostoru a tato sada
generátorů je bází tohoto podprostoru, přičemž máme na paměti, že jde o vektorový prostor, kde se aritmetika provádí modulo 2. Pokud máme M generátorů,
dostaneme kód mající 2 na M prvků, každý generátor zdvojnásobí počet prvků v kódu, a
to je konzistentní se skutečností, že klasické lineární kódy nad binární abecedou vždy obsahují počet řetězců, který je mocninou
dvou. Druhý přirozený způsob, jak popsat klasický lineární kód, je pomocí kontroly parity. Konkrétně jde o minimální
seznam binárních řetězců stejné délky jako řetězce v kódu, takový, že řetězce v kódu jsou přesně ty, jejichž binární
skalární součin s každým z těchto kontrolních řetězců parity je nula, přičemž binární skalární součin je jednoduše
obyčejný vnitřní součin modulo 2, a to je něco, s čím jsme se setkali v lekci pět v kontextu
algoritmů dotazování. A důvod, proč se jim říká kontrolní řetězce parity, je ten, že daný řetězec u má binární součin rovný
nule s v tehdy a jen tehdy, pokud bity u odpovídající jedničkám ve v mají sudou
paritu. Když popisujeme klasický lineární kód tímto způsobem pomocí minimálního seznamu kontrolních řetězců parity, každý
kontrolní řetězec parity vydělí počet řetězců v kódu dvěma. Takže pro jediný kód popsaný těmito dvěma různými způsoby budeme mít vždy m plus r rovno
n. Jedna důležitá věc, které si zde všimnout, je, že binární skalární součin není vnitřním součinem ve formálním smyslu, a
konkrétně, když dva řetězce mají binární skalární součin rovný nule, neznamená to, že jsou ortogonální v obvyklém smyslu, v jakém přemýšlíme o
ortogonalitě. Například binární skalární součin řetězce 11 se sebou samým je nula, takže je možné, že
jeden z těchto kontrolních řetězců parity je sám v kódu. To je jen něco, co je třeba mít
na paměti. Například, jak již víme, tříbitový opakovací kód je lineární kód, takže jej lze popsat oběma těmito
způsoby. Konkrétně existuje jen jedna volba generátoru, která funguje, a to 111, a alternativně ho lze popsat
těmito dvěma kontrolními řetězci parity, které by měly vypadat povědomě z našich předchozích diskusí o tomto
kódu. A pro Hammingův kód 7-4-3 lze použít tyto generátory a tyto kontrolní
řetězce parity, a mimochodem, všechny naše kontrolní řetězce parity se ukáží samy o sobě být v kódu.
Poslední poznámka o klasických lineárních kódech, jen abychom je propojili se stabilizátorovým formalizmem. Tyto kontrolní
řetězce parity jsou ekvivalentní generátorům stabilizátoru, kde máme jen Z a identitní Pauliho matice. Například kontrolní řetězce parity
110 a 011 pro tříbitový opakovací kód odpovídají přesně generátorům stabilizátoru ZZ identita
a identita ZZ, a to je konzistentní s naší diskusí pozorovatelných tohoto druhu z předchozí
lekce. Dále budeme diskutovat CSS kódy, což jsou stabilizátorové kódy, které lze získat kombinací určitých
párů klasických lineárních kódů se stejným počtem bitů v jejich kódováních. Toto nefunguje pro libovolné dva
klasické lineární kódy, tyto dva kódy musejí mít určitý vztah, jak uvidíme brzy, ale přesto tato
konstrukce otevírá mnoho možností pro kvantové kódy opravující chyby, vycházející částečně z věcí, které jsme se naučili za více než 75 let
klasické teorie kódování. Již jsem zmínil, že ve stabilizátorovém formalizmu
generátory stabilizátoru obsahující pouze Z a identitní Pauliho matice jsou ekvivalentní kontrolám parity. Například v tříbitovém
opakovacím kódu lze použít kontrolní řetězce parity 110 a 011, které vynucují, že dvě krajní levé bity jsou
shodné a dvě krajní pravé bity jsou shodné pro každý řetězec v kódu, a tyto dva kontrolní řetězce parity odpovídají přesně generátorům stabilizátoru
ZZ identita a identita ZZ. Pro Hammingův kód 7-4-3 lze použít
tyto kontrolní řetězce parity a odpovídají těmto generátorům stabilizátoru, kde jednoduše nahradíme každou jedničku Z a každou nulu identitou.
Tyto generátory stabilizátoru možná poznáš, protože jsou to tři ze šesti generátorů stabilizátoru pro sedmiqubitový Steanova kód. To
jistě není náhoda, a brzy uvidíme přesně, co se zde děje. Dáme název Z
generátorům stabilizátoru takovýmto generátorům, tedy takovým, které mají pouze Pauliho Z a identitní tensorové
faktory. X a Y se tedy nikdy nevyskytují v Z generátoru stabilizátoru. Lze také uvažovat
generátory stabilizátoru, kde se vyskytují pouze X a identitní Pauliho matice, a na tyto generátory stabilizátoru lze pohlížet jako zcela analogické
Z generátorům stabilizátoru, až na to, že v podstatě popisují kontroly parity v bázi plus mínus, nikoli ve
standardní bázi. Například přejdeme zpět k Hammingovu kódu 7-4-3 a zamyslíme se nad
zbývajícími třemi generátory stabilizátoru ze sedmiqubitového Steanova kódu, které sledují přesně stejný vzor jako Z generátory stabilizátoru pro tento
kód, ale tentokrát dosazujeme X za jedničku místo Z, a to, co dostaneme pouze z těchto tří generátorů stabilizátoru,
je kód, který zahrnuje 16 stavů zobrazených zde, které dostaneme aplikováním Hadamard gates na standardní
bázové stavy odpovídající řetězcům v Hammingově kódu 7-4-3. A samozřejmě náš kódový prostor také zahrnuje
lineární kombinace těchto stavů. Přirozeně, generátory stabilizátoru tohoto tvaru se nazývají X generátory stabilizátoru,
takže tentokrát nejsou povoleny žádné y ani z. A nyní můžeme definovat CSS kódy
jednoduše: CSS kódy jsou stabilizátorové kódy, které lze vyjádřit pomocí pouze Z
generátorů stabilizátoru a X generátorů stabilizátoru, takže žádné y nejsou povoleny a v jednom generátoru stabilizátoru se nesmějí vyskytovat x a z dohromady.
A jen abychom si byli jisti, že je to jasné, měli bychom mít na paměti, že existuje svoboda ve výběru generátorů stabilizátoru pro stabilizátorové
kódy, a co tato definice říká, je, že CSS kód je takový, pro který je možné zvolit pouze Z a X
generátory stabilizátoru. Ale obecně bys mohl zvolit různé generátory stabilizátoru, které nemusejí být Z nebo X generátory stabilizátoru, pokud bys chtěl.
Zde je téměř nejjednodušší netriviální příklad CSS kódu, který můžeme mít, kde existuje jak Z generátor stabilizátoru,
tak X generátor stabilizátoru, a ověření toho vyžaduje jen letmý pohled, protože z předchozí lekce již víme,
že jde o platný stabilizátorový kód. Kódový prostor je jednorozměrný, je to prostor rozepnutý vektorem ψ plus Bell, a můžeme
pozorovat, že naše dva generátory stabilizátoru působí triviálně na tento vektor uvažováním
dvou vyjádření ebitu zobrazených na obrazovce spolu s interpretací generátorů stabilizátoru jako kontrol parity v 0-1
a plus-mínus bázích. Sedmiqubitový Steanova kód je dalším příkladem CSS kódu, protože pro tuto
volbu generátorů máme pouze Z a X generátory stabilizátoru, a opět již víme, že jde o platný
stabilizátorový kód. A devítiqubitový Shorův kód je dalším příkladem. Tentokrát máme šest Z
generátorů stabilizátoru a pouze dva X generátory stabilizátoru, a to je v pořádku. Nemusí existovat rovnováha nebo
symetrie mezi oběma typy. Je však kriticky důležité, abychom skutečně měli platný stabilizátorový kód, a to znamená,
že každý Z generátor stabilizátoru musí komutovat s každým X generátorem stabilizátoru, takže nemůžeš
jednoduše nezávisle vybírat oba typy generátorů. O tom řeknu trochu víc později v lekci. Dále probereme detekci
a korekci chyb u CSS kódů, a co zjistíme, je, že vlastnost, kterou jsme pozorovali u devítiqubitového Shorova
kódu, totiž že lze detekovat a opravovat X chyby a Z chyby nezávisle, platí obecně pro CSS kódy.
K dalšímu vysvětlení uvažme CSS kód, například sedmiqubitový Steanova kód, ale mohl by to být i jiný CSS kód, pokud
chceš. Základní myšlenka je, že Z generátory stabilizátoru detekují X chyby,
ale jsou zcela slepé k Z chybám, protože Z generátory stabilizátoru vždy komutují se Z
chybami. Navíc Z generátory stabilizátoru také komutují s jakýmikoli Z gates, které bychom mohli zvolit k aplikování jako
korekce Z chyb. Podobně X generátory stabilizátoru detekují Z chyby, ale jsou zcela
slepé k X chybám a korekcím. Takže v podstatě si lze myslet o Z generátorech stabilizátoru jako o reprezentaci
klasického lineárního kódu, který chrání proti přehozením bitů, neboli jinak řečeno X chybám, zatímco X generátory stabilizátoru
reprezentují klasický lineární kód v bázi plus mínus, který zcela nezávisle chrání proti přehozením
mezi stavy plus a mínus, neboli jinak řečeno chybám fázového přehození či Z chybám. Nyní je tedy zcela zřejmé, co se
děje se Steanovým kódem: je to jednoduše Hammingův kód 7-4-3 pro chyby přehození bitů a Hammingův kód 7-4-3 pro chyby
fázového přehození. Opět platí, že je vyžadováno, aby Z generátory stabilizátoru a X generátory stabilizátoru komutovaly.
Bez toho by nešlo o platný stabilizátorový kód, a mohl bys říct, že je to šťastná náhoda, že Hammingův kód 7-4-3
funguje takto, ale existuje mnoho dalších voleb, které lze provést pro páry klasických lineárních kódů, jež nám dají platný stabilizátorový kód
při takovémto kombinování. Nyní se vraťme k CSS kódům obecně a předpokládejme, že Z generátory stabilizátoru
umožňují korekci až řekněme j X chyb a X generátory stabilizátoru umožňují korekci
až k Z chyb. Takže v případě Steanova kódu jsou j a k oba jedna, protože
Hammingův kód 7-4-3 může opravit jedno přehození bitu. Ale obecně tato čísla j a k mohou být různá.
Z toho pak plyne diskretizací chyb, že CSS kód může opravit libovolnou chybu na počtu qubit rovném
minimu z j a k. Je to proto, že když měříme syndrom, libovolná chyba na určitém
počtu qubit efektivně probabilisticky kolabuje do nějaké kombinace X chyb, Z chyb nebo obojího, a pak
lze X chyby a Z chyby detekovat a korigovat nezávisle. Takže pokud máme dva
klasické lineární kódy, které se shodnou v tom smyslu, že nám dávají X a Z generátory stabilizátoru, které komutují,
CSS kód, který dostaneme jejich kombinováním, v podstatě zdědí vlastnosti korekce chyb obou kódů ve smyslu, který jsem právě
popsal. Všimni si, že za to se platí cena, a to ta, že nemůžeme zakódovat tolik qubit, kolik bychom mohli zakódovat bitů
s oběma klasickými kódy, protože celkový počet generátorů stabilizátoru pro CSS kód je součet
počtu kontrol parity pro oba klasické kódy, a každý generátor stabilizátoru zmenší dimenzi kódového prostoru na
polovinu. Například Hammingův kód 7-4-3 umožňuje zakódovat čtyři klasické bity, protože máme pouze
tři kontroly parity pro tento kód, zatímco sedmiqubitový Steanova kód zakóduje pouze jeden qubit, protože má šest
generátorů stabilizátoru. Poslední věcí, kterou v této lekci vysvětlím o CSS kódech obecně, se týká kódových prostorů CSS kódů
a toho, jak vypadají. To nám také dá příležitost podrobněji prozkoumat vztah, který musí platit mezi
dvěma klasickými lineárními kódy, aby byly kompatibilní v tom smyslu, že je lze kombinovat do CSS
kódu. Uvažme libovolný CSS kód na N qubitech a nechť Z1 až Zs jsou n-bitové
kontrolní řetězce parity odpovídající Z generátorům stabilizátoru. To znamená, že klasický
lineární kód popsaný Z generátory stabilizátoru, který budeme nazývat CZ, jen abychom si pamatovali, že jde o
kód odpovídající Z generátorům stabilizátoru, má tvar zobrazený na obrazovce. Slovy, kód obsahuje každý
řetězec u, jehož binární skalární součin s každým z kontrolních řetězců parity je nula. Kdybychom chtěli, mohli bychom také
uvažovat jiný kód odvozený z těchto stejných řetězců, který budeme nazývat DZ, a myšlenka je, že
uvažujeme tyto řetězce Z1 až Zs nikoli jako kontrolní řetězce parity, ale jako generátory.
V tuto chvíli není jasné, proč bychom o tomto kódu chtěli uvažovat, ale můžeme, a ukáže se to být relevantní pro tuto
diskusi. Tento kód se nazývá duální kód CZ a běžně se označuje CZ perp, tedy CZ se superscriptem symbolu kolmice,
ale my ho budeme nazývat DZ, a to si snadno zapamatujeme, protože D je zkratka
pro duální. Podobně lze postupovat s X generátory stabilizátoru, takže tentokrát CX je klasický lineární kód,
jehož kontrolní řetězce parity odpovídají X generátorům stabilizátoru, a DX je duální kód tohoto kódu. Jako poznámka na okraj
nyní lze popsat podmínky, které musejí platit, aby CZ a CX byly kompatibilní ve smyslu, že je lze
spárovat jako CSS kód. Z hlediska těchto kódů samotných musí konkrétně platit, že
DZ je obsaženo v CX, nebo ekvivalentně, že DX je obsaženo v CZ. A nyní je
možné popsat kódový prostor CSS kódu odvozený z těchto dvou kódů. Jedním způsobem, jak ho popsat, je, že
jde o prostor rozepnutý všemi vektory tvaru zobrazeného na obrazovce. Slovy vypadají jako uniformní
superpozice přes řetězce v duálním kódu DX kódu odpovídajícího X generátorům stabilizátoru, posunuté
neboli XOR'd s řetězci v kódu CZ odpovídajícím Z generátorům stabilizátoru, a za chvíli uvidíme, jak to vypadá
v konkrétním případě Steanova kódu. To dává smysl, protože stavy v kódovém prostoru musejí být
vlastními vektory vlastní hodnoty plus jedna všech generátorů stabilizátoru, a konkrétně násobení libovolným z X
generátorů stabilizátoru je ekvivalentní XOR s odpovídajícím X řetězcem. Proto se tyto uniformní superpozice
přes DX posunuté různými řetězci takto objevují. Různé volby posunutí
reprezentované řetězcem Y v tomto vyjádření mohou mimochodem dát stejný vektor, takže tyto stavy nejsou všechny odlišné, ale dohromady rozepínají
celý kódový prostor. Existuje symetrie mezi X a Z generátory stabilizátoru a
kódy, kterým odpovídají, takže tuto symetrii můžeme použít k popisu vektorů v kódovém prostoru analogickým způsobem záměnou x a z, ale
musíme také zaměnit standardní báze za báze plus mínus, a proto se operace Hadamard vyskytují v tomto
vyjádření. Nyní pro slíbený příklad, tedy Steanova kód, dostaneme tato dvě zakódovaná možná
kódování stavů nula a jedna ve standardní bázi. Konkrétně stav nula lze zakódovat jako uniformní
superpozici osmi řetězců v duálním kódu Hammingova kódu 7-4-3, který se ukáže být polovinou řetězců Hammingova kódu 7-4-3, a
stav jedna lze zakódovat podobným způsobem, až na to, že všechny řetězce jsou XOR'd řetězcem samých jedniček v tomto případě,
protože tento řetězec se nachází v Hammingově kódu 7-4-3, ale ne v jeho duálním kódu. Jedna závěrečná poznámka: často
nám vůbec tolik nezáleží na tom, jak vypadají vektory v našich kódových prostorech, protože k používání
kódů to obecně vědět nepotřebujeme. Takže pokud toto vysvětlení nebylo jasné, není to vůbec nic, o co by ses měl starat příliš, ale je to
jistě přirozené ptát se, jak vypadají vektory v kódových prostorech CSS kódů, a tento popis poskytuje odpověď na tuto
otázku. Dále budeme diskutovat konkrétní CSS kód známý jako Toricův kód, což je příklad něčeho, co je známé jako
topologický kvantový kód opravující chyby. Tento kód byl objeven Alexejem Kitaevem v
roce 1997. Ve skutečnosti Toricův kód není jediný kód, ale spíše rodina kódů, jeden pro každé kladné celé číslo alespoň
dvě. Tyto kódy mají několik klíčových vlastností. První klíčová vlastnost je,
že všechny generátory stabilizátoru mají nízkou váhu jako Pauliho operace. Konkrétně budou mít všechny
váhu čtyři, a to je dobré, protože to znamená, že každé měření generátoru stabilizátoru nemusí
zahrnovat příliš mnoho qubit. Někdy se mluví o kvantových LDPC kódech, neboli kvantových kódech s nízkou hustotou kontrol parity,
a tímto termínem se míní to, že v tomto případě nízká znamená čtyři. Takže Toricův kód je příkladem
kvantového LDPC kódu. Toricův kód má také takzvanou geometrickou lokalitu, což znamená, že nejen
generátory stabilizátoru mají nízkou váhu, ale je také možné prostorově uspořádat qubity tak, aby
každé měření generátoru stabilizátoru zahrnovalo pouze qubity, které jsou blízko sebe, což tato měření v
zásadě usnadňuje implementaci. A nakonec tyto kódy mají velkou vzdálenost, takže mohou tolerovat relativně vysokou míru
chyb. Zde je, jak tyto kódy fungují. Nejdříve nechť L je kladné
celé číslo, které je alespoň dvě, a uvažme mřížku L krát L s takzvanými periodickými
hranicemi. Například zde je mřížka L krát L pro L rovno 8. Všimni si, že čáry
vpravo a dole jsou tečkované čáry, a myšlenka je, že tečkovanou čáru vpravo chceme považovat za totožnou s čárou
vlevo, a podobně tečkovaná čára dole je totožná s čárou
nahoře. Takže kdybychom tuto konfiguraci chtěli fyzicky realizovat, potřebovali bychom tři
rozměry. Konkrétně bychom mohli vytvořit válec nejdříve spojením levé a pravé strany a pak ohnout
válec tak, aby se kruhy na koncích, které bývaly horní a dolní okraje mřížky, setkaly, nebo
bychom mohli nejdříve spojit horní a dolní stranu a pak strany. Funguje to oběma způsoby a nezáleží na tom, jak to uděláš, pro účely této
diskuse. Co dostaneme, je torus, neboli jinými slovy donut, přestože si ho raději představit jako duši pneumatiky
je možná lepší obraz, protože nejde o pevné těleso. Mřížka se stala pouze povrchem
toru, a odtud pochází název Toricův kód. Způsob, jakým se lze pohybovat
na takovém toru, za předpokladu, že se pohybuješ mezi sousedními body na mřížce, bude pravděpodobně povědomý lidem, kteří hráli staré videohry,
kde pokud opustíš horní okraj obrazovky, vynoříš se dole, a stejně tak pro levý a pravý okraj
obrazovky. A z větší části budu tuto mřížku popisovat takto, jako alternativu k hovoru konkrétně o toru
v trojrozměrném prostoru. Dále si představíme, že qubity jsou
umístěny na hranách mřížky, jak je znázorněno na obrazovce, kde qubity jsou označeny plnými modrými
kruhy. Všimni si mimochodem, že qubity umístěné na tečkovaných čarách nejsou plné, protože tyto qubity jsme již reprezentovali
buď těmi nahoře nebo na levé straně, přičemž máme na paměti, že čáry nahoře a vlevo jsou přesně stejné čáry jako ty
označené tečkovanými čarami dole a vpravo. A pokud spočítáme všechny tyto qubity, dostaneme 2 krát L na druhou qubit. Jeden
způsob, jak to vidět, je pozorovat, že dostaneme L na druhou qubit na horizontálních hranách a L na druhou qubit na vertikálních
hranách. Takové je tedy rozmístění našich qubit, a k popisu samotného Toricova kódu stačí popsat generátory stabilizátoru.
Existují dva jejich typy. Za prvé máme Z generátory stabilizátoru
a ty odpovídají dlaždicím neboli plakettám na obrázku. Za druhé máme X generátory stabilizátoru
a ty odpovídají vrcholům na obrázku. Zde je například jeden
generátor stabilizátoru, což znamená, že tensorujeme dohromady jednu operaci Pauliho Z pro každý qubit dotýkající se této dlaždice spolu s identickými maticemi
na všech ostatních qubitech, a to nám dává Pauliho operaci váhy čtyři. A zde je příklad X
generátoru stabilizátoru, kde Pauliho X matice působí na čtyři qubity incidentní s tímto vrcholem spolu s
identickými maticemi na všech ostatních qubitech. Takže opět jde o Pauliho operaci váhy čtyři. Je důležité, že pro oba
typy generátorů stabilizátoru zahrnujeme ty, které se obtáčejí kolem periodických hranic. A zde je příklad X generátoru stabilizátoru,
který to dělá. Aby byl platný stabilizátorový kód, potřebujeme, aby generátory stabilizátoru
komutovaly. Z generátory stabilizátoru mezi sebou navzájem komutují, protože Z komutuje sama se sebou a identita
komutuje se vším, a stejně tak X generátory stabilizátoru. Je také jasné, že Z generátor stabilizátoru a X
generátor stabilizátoru komutují, pokud netriviálně působí na disjunktních sadách qubit, jako pro dva generátory zobrazené
zde. Zbývající možnost je, že Z generátor stabilizátoru a X generátor stabilizátoru se překrývají, a
kdykoli k tomu dojde, vždy se překrývají na dvou qubitech, takže generátory stabilizátoru komutují, protože ZZ
a XX komutují. Nyní toto není minimální sada generátorů stabilizátoru. Konkrétně, pokud vynásobíme
všechny Z generátory stabilizátoru dohromady, dostaneme identitu, protože každý qubit je vynásoben Z dvakrát,
jednou pro každou z dlaždic, které se qubit dotýkají. To znamená, že vynásobení všech Z generátorů stabilizátoru dohromady
kromě jednoho nám dá ten poslední, takže nejsou nezávislé. Ale pokud odebereme libovolný jeden z nich, dostaneme
nezávislou sadu, a totéž platí pro X generátory stabilizátoru. Takže můžeme odebrat jeden z každého
a nezáleží na tom, které odebereme. To nám zanechá L na druhou mínus jedna generátorů stabilizátoru každého typu. Jen abychom to
upřesnili, a to je něco, na co jsem narazil v předchozí lekci, skutečně nám záleží na všech těchto generátorech stabilizátoru, a v přísně
operačním smyslu ve skutečnosti nevybereme jeden z každého typu k ignorování, ale pro účely analýzy kódu si
představíme, že byl odebrán jeden generátor stabilizátoru každého typu, takže dostaneme minimální generující sadu, přičemž máme na paměti,
že výsledky těchto odebraných generátorů, uvažovaných jako pozorovatelné, bychom vždy mohli odvodit z výsledků všech ostatních generátorů stabilizátoru
stejného typu. Počet qubit, které tento kód kóduje, se tedy rovná celkovému počtu
qubit, což je 2 krát L na druhou, minus celkový počet generátorů stabilizátoru v minimální generující sadě, což je 2 krát L na druhou mínus
1. To znamená, že můžeme zakódovat 2 qubity. Mimochodem jsem neargumentoval, že kódový prostor je netriviální, ale skutečně
je netriviální, a nechám tě přesvědčit sám sebe, že neexistuje způsob, jak vynásobit generátory stabilizátoru tak, abychom dostali
mínus jedna krát identitu. Takže to je samotný Toricův kód, a v tomto okamžiku vůbec
nemusí být jasné, proč by tento kód měl být dobrý pro kvantovou korekci chyb. Zbývá ho analyzovat, a co zjistíme, je, že je to
ve skutečnosti dost úžasný kvantový kód opravující chyby. Abychom pochopili, jak Toricův kód funguje jako kvantový kód opravující chyby,
začneme uvažováním různých chyb a syndromů, které generují. První věcí, které si všimnout, je, že
Toricův kód je CSS kód, protože všechny naše generátory stabilizátoru jsou buď Z nebo X generátory stabilizátoru.
A to znamená, že X chyby a Z chyby lze detekovat a případně korigovat
odděleně. A ve skutečnosti existuje jednoduchá symetrie mezi Z a X generátory stabilizátoru, která nám umožňuje analyzovat X
chyby a Z chyby v podstatě stejným způsobem. Takže se soustředím na X chyby, které jsou případně detekovány Z
generátory stabilizátoru, a vše pro Z chyby, které jsou případně detekovány X generátory stabilizátoru, lze přeložit pomocí přesně stejných
myšlenek. Zde je obrázek znázorňující naše qubity na hranách mřížky L
krát L s periodickými hranicemi, a lze si představit, že je rozmístěno na povrchu
toru. V tuto chvíli jsou všechny qubity modré, což znamená, že jde o qubity, které nebyly ovlivněny
chybami. Takže si představ, že v tuto chvíli je stav těchto qubit v kódovém prostoru tohoto
kódu. Jak jsem zmínil, zaměříme se na X chyby, a za chvíli budeme používat purpurové kruhy k označení qubit, které
byly ovlivněny X chybami. X chyby jsou detekovány Z generátory stabilizátoru, které odpovídají
dlaždicím na obrázku. Co tedy můžeme udělat, je nechat bílé dlaždice označovat výsledky měření plus jedna, neboli jinými slovy
záznamy v syndromu odpovídající tomuto generátoru, zatímco šedé dlaždice budou označovat výsledky měření minus jedna.
Výsledek plus jedna, neboli jinými slovy bílá dlaždice, si lze představit jako indikátor, že odpovídající
generátor stabilizátoru je spokojený, vše vypadá v pořádku pro tento generátor, zatímco výsledek minus jedna neboli šedá dlaždice
indikuje, že odpovídající generátor stabilizátoru je nespokojený, protože zjevně musela nastat chyba, aby způsobila tento
výsledek. Takže v tuto chvíli jsou všechny naše generátory stabilizátoru spokojené, protože nedošlo k žádným chybám. Uvažme nyní
Z generátor stabilizátoru: vše, co dělá, je měřit paritu 4 qubit dotýkajících se dlaždice s
ohledem na standardní bázi. Výsledek plus jedna tedy neindikuje, že u těchto čtyř qubit nedošlo k žádné X chybě, ale
spíše to indikuje, že došlo k sudému počtu X chyb, zatímco výsledek minus jedna indikuje,
že došlo k lichému počtu X chyb. Zaveďme tedy X chybu a uvidíme, co
se stane. Dva Z generátory stabilizátoru odpovídající dlaždicím, které se dotýkají tohoto qubitu, jsou nyní nespokojené, protože tato
X chyba antikomutuje s oběma těmito generátory, nebo ekvivalentně, z hlediska standardní báze se nyní nacházíme ve
stavu, kde oba tyto soubory čtyř qubit odpovídající dvěma dlaždicím mají lichou paritu. To je tedy efekt jedné
X chyby. Takže kdybychom měřili tento syndrom a věděli nebo předpokládali, že došlo jen k jedné X chybě, snadno bychom
odvodili, který qubit se přehodil, a jednoduše bychom ho přehodili zpět pomocí X gate. Nyní se podívejme, co se stane,
když zavedeme další X chyby, a konkrétně, co se stane, když druhá X chyba nastane na jiném
qubitu dotýkajícím se jedné ze šedých dlaždic, řekněme šedé dlaždice nahoře,
například takto. Tato dlaždice je nyní spokojená, protože na qubitech dotýkajících se této dlaždice došlo ke dvěma X chybám, a dvě je sudé číslo, takže
tyto dvě X chyby dohromady komutují s generátorem stabilizátoru pro tuto dlaždici. Jiný způsob, jak to říci, je, že
tato druhá X chyba posunula všechny standardní bázové stavy těchto čtyř qubit z liché parity zpět na sudou
paritu. Dlaždice vlevo od této nové X chyby je na druhou stranu nyní nespokojená.
Lze pokračovat v tomto procesu přidávání nových X chyb, a pokud tvoříme řetězec sousedních X chyb, kde sousední znamená, že se qubity dotýkají
téže dlaždice, efektivně tím posouváme tento výsledek měření mínus jedna dále a dále. A co zjistíme, je, že vždy máme
výsledky měření syndromu mínus jedna na koncových bodech řetězců sousedních chyb. Takže vždy můžeme detekovat řetězce
sousedních X chyb, pokud mají koncové body. Mimochodem může existovat více řetězců, ale k této možnosti se
vrátíme později. Je však možné, že máme řetězec sousedních X chyb, který
nemá koncové body, tedy naše řetěz chyb by mohla tvořit uzavřenou smyčku. Přidejme tedy více chyb tak,
aby tvořily uzavřenou smyčku jako například takto. Nyní máme sudý počet X
chyb na každé dlaždici, takže každý generátor stabilizátoru je nyní spokojený, a zjistili jsme, že uzavřené
smyčky sousedních X chyb nejsou tímto kódem detekovány, protože v takovém případě dostaneme syndrom samých plus jedna.
To by mohlo vypadat trochu zklamáním, ve skutečnosti k vytvoření uzavřené smyčky stačí pouze čtyři sousední X chyby,
a doufáme v něco lepšího než kód se vzdáleností 4. Nicméně některé uzavřené smyčky
sousedních X chyb samy jsou ve stabilizátoru. Pamatuj, že pro každý vrchol v mřížce máme X generátor stabilizátoru,
a pokud vynásobíme sousední X generátory stabilizátoru, lze tvořit uzavřené smyčky X
operací, jako máme právě zde pro uzavřenou smyčku, kterou jsme zkonstruovali před chvílí. Takže některé uzavřené smyčky X chyb,
jako ta, která je zde zobrazena, ve skutečnosti vůbec nejsou chybami, protože jsou ve stabilizátoru, takže kódovému prostoru vůbec nic nedělají. Existují však
uzavřené smyčky X chyb, které nejsou ve stabilizátoru, a proto představují netriviální chyby, jež
kód nedetekuje. A existuje docela jednoduchý způsob, jak charakterizovat různé typy
smyček. Smyčky, které křižují každou čáru v mřížce, tedy každou vertikální čáru od shora dolů a každou horizontální čáru
zleva doprava, sudý počet krát, jsou vždy součiny X generátorů stabilizátoru. To zahrnuje zobrazený příklad
na obrazovce, jakož i smyčky, které mohou být mnohem komplikovanější, včetně možnosti, že překračují periodické hranice, ale
přesto vynásobením těchto uzavřených smyček X chyb X generátory stabilizátoru je lze efektivně zmenšit až na
nic. A samozřejmě je pravdou, že takové smyčky lze získat pouze násobením X generátorů stabilizátoru, protože každý X generátor stabilizátoru
klade sudý počet X operací na každou horizontální čáru a na každou vertikální
čáru. Druhý typ uzavřené smyčky, který můžeme mít, je takový, který kříží alespoň jednu čáru lichý počet krát, jako
ten zobrazený zde, který kříží každou horizontální čáru přesně jednou. A zde je další příklad, který kříží
každou vertikální čáru přesně jednou. Takže jde o příklady netriviálních chyb, které kód nedetekuje. Ale klíč
je, že jediný způsob, jak takovouto uzavřenou smyčku tvořit, je obtočit se kolem toru, buď kolem díry uprostřed
toru, nebo skrze díru, nebo to může být obojí. Jde o topologickou vlastnost
toru, v zásadě jde o díry, a proto se tento kód nazývá topologický kvantový kód opravující
chyby. Z hlediska tohoto zobrazení dvourozměrné mřížky s periodickými hranicemi musí řetěz v této kategorii
obejít jednu nebo obě periodické hranice způsobem, který znemožňuje zmenšit tuto smyčku na
bod násobením X generátory stabilizátoru. Takový řetěz může být
komplikovanější než ten, který je zde znázorněn, ale toto je nejkratší, jaký taková smyčka vůbec může být, protože musí nějak obejít
jednu nebo obě periodické hranice. A co to implikuje, je, že minimální váha netriviální
nedetekovatelné chyby je L. Jakákoli uzavřená smyčka s méně chybami než tolik musí patřit do první kategorie a je proto
ve stabilizátoru. A řetězy chyb, které netvoří uzavřené smyčky, jsou kódem detekovány. A to je vše, proto tento kód
funguje. A výsledkem je stabilizátorový kód 2L²-2-L. Používáme 2L² qubit ke kódování 2 qubit a kód má vzdálenost L.
Dále řeknu jen trochu o korekci chyb pomocí Toricova kódu, přestože do detailů příliš nezajdu. Pokud změříme syndrom a
uvidíme něco jiného než syndrom samých plus jedna, přičemž zde mluvím pouze o Z generátorech stabilizátoru,
pak výsledky mínus jedna nám indikují koncové body jednoho nebo více řetězců sousedních X chyb, a můžeme se pokusit korigovat
tyto chyby spárováním výsledků mínus jedna a tvořením řetězu X korekcí mezi nimi. A při
tom dává smysl volit nejkratší cesty pro naše korekce. Například pokud změříme
syndrom jako ten zobrazený zde, pak bychom mohli zvolit tuto cestu mezi nespokojenými dlaždicemi a aplikovat X
gates jako korekce podél této cesty. Skutečný řetěz chyb způsobující syndrom samozřejmě mohl
být jiný, jako ten zobrazený zde, ale to je v pořádku, pokud chyby a korekce dohromady
patří do stabilizátoru. Mohlo by také dojít k tomu, že naše korekce dokončí smyčku kolem
toru, což je špatné, protože tím jsme způsobili logickou chybu. Tato strategie korekce
podél nejkratších cest opravuje nízkovážné chyby, ale nemusí fungovat pro chyby s vyšší vahou. Ale samozřejmě od žádného
kvantového kódu opravujícího chyby nemůžeme očekávat více. Pravděpodobnější možná, v závislosti na modelu šumu, je, že
pozorujeme hromadu výsledků mínus jedna v syndromu, a v tomto případě můžeme použít efektivní klasické algoritmy, které
nám pomohou je spárovat a najít chybu s nejnižší vahou reprezentující syndrom. Jak jsem zmínil v předchozí
lekci, nemusí to vždy opravit nejpravděpodobnější vysvětlení syndromu, ale obecně funguje docela dobře
a vždy uspěje v korekci chyb s váhou striktně menší než polovina vzdálenosti L. A měl bych také
zmínit, že existují jiné strategie, které jsou lépe přizpůsobeny různým modelům chyb. Uplynulo více než 25 let od
objevu Toricova kódu, a za tu dobu bylo provedeno dosti mnoho práce na kvantových kódech opravujících chyby, včetně
jiných topologických kvantových kódů opravujících chyby inspirovaných Toricovým kódem, jakož i kódů založených na různých
myšlenkách. Jistě ti nemohu poskytnout úplný seznam všech různých konstrukcí kódů, které jsou známy, ale trochu se dotkneme povrchu
a stručně zmíníme několik dobře známých příkladů. Za prvé, jak se ukáže, není
vůbec nezbytné, aby Toricův kód měl periodické hranice, tedy je možné vyřezat jen část Toricova kódu a
rozložit ho naplocho na dvourozměrný povrch, nikoli na torus, a to, co tím získáme, se nazývá povrchový
kód. Například pokud vyřežeme hrany mřížky ve vzoru zobrazeném zde s takzvanými hrubými hranami nahoře
a dole a hladkými hranami po stranách, a odpovídajícím způsobem zahrneme hraniční případy pro generátory stabilizátoru,
dostaneme kód, který tentokrát může zakódovat pouze jeden qubit, ale tento kód přesto zdědí nejdůležitější
charakteristiky Toricova kódu. Konkrétně netriviální nedetekovatelné chyby pro tento kód musejí
odpovídat řetězům chyb, které se táhnou buď od levého okraje k pravému, nebo od horního k dolnímu,
v závislosti na tom, zda jde o řetězy X chyb nebo Z chyb. Je také možné vyřezat
hrany diagonálně a získat tak, čemu se někdy říká rotované povrchové kódy, a tím lze dosáhnout toho, aby
kódy byly ekonomičtější z hlediska počtu použitých qubit. Například vezmeme-li tento povrchový
kód a vyhodíme část qubit, přičemž ponecháme čtverec orientovaný diagonálně, dostaneme jiný povrchový
kód, pokud správně specifikujeme generátory stabilizátoru na hranici. Diagramy jako tento jsou
užitečné pro objasnění toho, jak jsou generátory stabilizátoru definovány, kde černé dlaždice včetně zaoblených na okrajích indikují X generátory stabilizátoru
a bílé indikují Z generátory stabilizátoru. Ty na hranici jsou mimochodem pouze dvouqubitové XX
nebo ZZ generátory stabilizátoru tentokrát. A tyto diagramy uvidíš běžně otočené o
45°. Jinou zajímavou třídou kódů, která také spadá do obecné kategorie topologických kódů, jsou barevné
kódy. Nebudu přesně vysvětlovat, jak fungují, ale jeden způsob, jak na ně myslet, je, že jsou to geometrická zobecnění
sedmiqubitového Steanova kódu. Uvažme tedy sedmiqubitový Steanova kód a předpokládejme, že číslujeme naše
qubity pomocí konvence uspořádání KCET, jak je zobrazeno na obrazovce. Pak můžeme přiřadit těchto sedm
qubit vrcholům grafu zobrazeného zde, a co zjistíme, je, že generátory stabilizátoru se shodují
s dlaždicemi neboli stěnami tvořenými hranami grafu, a pro každou dlaždici vždy máme Z generátor stabilizátoru
a X generátor stabilizátoru, které netriviálně působí přesně na ty qubity, které se nacházejí na vrcholech této
dlaždice. To je hezké, protože stejně jako pro Toricův kód máme geometrickou lokalitu pro tento kód, takže nepotřebujeme
přesouvat qubity na velké vzdálenosti pro měření generátorů stabilizátoru, a skutečnost, že Z a X generátory stabilizátoru vždy netriviálně působí na
přesně stejné sady qubit, je také hezká z důvodů souvisejících s bezporuchovou kvantovou výpočetní technikou, o čemž
řeknu více v příští lekci. Barevné kódy jsou kvantové kódy opravující chyby, které zobecňují tento
základní vzor, kde v podstatě děláme totéž, ale s různými grafy. Například zde je graf s
19 vrcholy, který funguje. To nám dá kód, který kóduje 1 qubit do 19, a má vzdálenost
pět. Tyto kódy se nazývají barevné kódy mimochodem proto, že jednou z požadovaných podmínek na graf je, že stěny lze tříbarevit, tedy
stěny lze obarvit třemi barvami tak, že žádné dvě stěny stejné barvy nesdílejí hranu. Barvy
ve skutečnosti pro samotný kód nezáleží, jednoduše máme X a Z generátory stabilizátoru pro každou stěnu bez ohledu na její barvu, ale barvy
se ukazují být důležité pro analýzu toho, jak funguje. Takže to jsou dvě dobře známé
rodiny kódů, ale existuje mnoho dalších konstrukcí, které jsou známy, včetně těch, které jsou založeny na myšlenkách podobných těmto rodinám kódů, jakož i
zcela odlišných. Konkrétním příkladem kvantového kódu opravujícího chyby, který byl nedávno
objeven některými z mých kolegů v IBM, je tak zvaný gross kód, pojmenovaný proto, že gross je tucet
tuctů neboli 144. Konkrétně tento kód kóduje 12 qubit do 144 qubit a má
vzdálenost 12. Nebudu podrobně vysvětlovat, jak tento kód funguje. Je podobný Toricovu kódu, až na to, že každý z
generátorů stabilizátoru nyní zahrnuje dva další qubity, které jsou jen o trochu dál. Nemá planární vnoření
jako povrchový kód, ale má takzvané biplanární vnoření, což znamená, že jsou potřeba dvě vrstvy qubit, nikoli
jen jedna. Patří do rodiny kódů nazývané bivariantní bicyklické kódy, a co je na nich zvlášť pozoruhodné, je,
že jsou mnohem efektivnější než Toricův kód nebo povrchový kód v tom smyslu, že lze zakódovat mnohem více qubit, a přitom
tolerují přibližně stejnou míru chyb. Pro gross kód je pro měření syndromu zapotřebí dalších 144 qubit,
takže celkový počet požadovaných qubit je 288, což z něj dělá velmi slibného kandidáta pro dnešní
technologie. A tím tato lekce, která pojednávala o konstrukcích kvantových kódů opravujících chyby, včetně CSS kódů, Toricova kódu a
nahlédnutí do dalších konstrukcí kvantových kódů, včetně povrchových kódů a barevných kódů, končí. Doufám, že se ke mně přidáš na příští
a poslední lekci série o bezporuchové kvantové výpočetní technice, která řeší výzvu provádění
výpočtů na zakódovaných kvantových stavech pomocí operací a výpočetních komponent, které jsou samy náchylné k
chybám.
Nashledanou.